donc vous allez sur le site des
républicains on ouvre largement et pas
seulement donc aux adhérents les
républicains notre idée non mais je vais
vous montrer notre idée c'est vraiment
que tous les Français qui le souhaitent
et il y a une soif de participer
aujourd'hui puissent déposer leurs
contribution donc vous allez sur le site
desrpublicains.fr on met le projet au au
centre au cœur vous avez donc l'onglet
projet vous mettez je particip parcipe
et là vous avez une case pour mettre je
participe donc participer vous créez
votre compte c'est très simple à faire
avec votre adresse mail et un mot de
passe et vous avez les contributions qui
viennent d'être déposées donc comme
venez de de le dire Éric on aura sans
doute d'ici la fin de la semaine à peu
près un millier de de contributions on
les modère bien évidemment et quand vous
cliquez sur
contribution donc là on est à faire une
proposition voilà on a par ex exemple
déjà sur le temps de travail une
première
contribution une personne qui a voulu
s'exprimer sur l'allocation de libre
choix une autre sur les gains de
productivité dans les entreprises une
autre sur le dossier médical
personnalisé et cetera et cetera donc
vous avez une rentrée par 19
thématiques qui ressemble grosso modo à
nos 19 groupes de travail et vous pouvez
mais de façon très très très simple
déposeer votre contribute